this is actually what my heart looks
like simple work II I wish I had some
elaborate April Fool's prank for you but
I don't
or don't it it could happen at any
moment during this video let's talk
about March favourites here are some of
the things that I really enjoyed during
the month of March first yeah you say
yeah say yeah yeah say yeah this is a
foundation that I've enjoyed very much
this is called rainforest of the sea
it's by Tarte look at that product shot
I have no clue what the title actually
means rainforest of the sea
maybe tart just got so sick of all the
over-sexualize make up names that they
were like [ __ ] just put a nonsense on it
don't be a chicken of the sea time to be
a rainforest of the sea i'll
sophisticate it this is water foundation
I don't know what that means either some
reason I followed tart on Instagram and
they started posting all of these photos
of girls using this foundation and I
really like tarts foundation so I got it
myself and guess what I really liked it
but there is something about it that I
do not like this lid is like a pump like
you push it down and you like get the
foundation and when you push it it goes
back in but I cannot grip this lid will
enough to push down the button and so it
just slides out of my hand
of algis losing a my where they're
getting a delivery or goose tried too
hard to understand what rainforest of
the semen any weight super lightweight
it goes on very smoothly it doesn't feel
like you're wearing any foundation it
covers pretty well and it's got a lot of
question marks to it and that makes me
like it next yeah yeah say yeah yeah say
ah I outside making a blending
foundation it's this Beauty Blender by
Real Techniques look at it it's got a
rounded normal Beauty Blender sided then
KaBlam me whoa rebellious I choose music
for a career instead of college teen
side I got this Beauty Blender off of
Amazon Prime now because it was just
there and I thought I haven't been
excessive
lately let's do this and I really love
it I like the option of smashing
something on my face that has different
angles and I like the orange the orange
doesn't make it look as scummy when it's
covered in scum next yeah si o si o si
is the bronzer by Too Faced called
chocolate should Shola which i think
translates to chocolate sun shame on
your to face for going into my dreams
and stealing one of my ideas and using
it for the name of your makeup product I
should be getting a back-end on this
insert your anal sex jokes here yes sir
shut down this is a matte bronzer ooh
see it production the thing I like the
most about this is that it actually
smells like chocolate I mean what I'm a
stereotype I I get it like I get it I
get it but this is great and for all of
you that I've ever wanted to like lick
your bronzer now you have more reason to
neck now se hace ah can you see em this
is a cream lip stain that I'm actually
wearing on my lips right now it's from
Sephora brought up shot this is in the
color made in Italy which I am NOT so
it's always nice to experience culture
in various ways you're made in Italy and
I'm made in the factory where they
produce cliche internet girls it's like
a Coralie color
feels like it's gonna be nice for spring
and summer because magazines tell us
that these colors are nice for spring
and summer and it truly is a stay it
does not come off your lips so that's
something I really like because I am
awful with lipstick lipstick provides a
real like new layer of anxiety to my
already really deep social anxiety but
thankfully this cream lip stain is like
a little bit of vicodin on your lips no
terrible terrible awful incorrect
metaphor next yeah say yeah yeah say
yeah I'll say this is not the actual
product the actual product is installed
in my house but this is representational
of it my next favorite is a shower head
yep so goodbye any bill any oh that was
watching this video thank you for your
time I know
I know it's called a Roma sense I can't
take credit for finding this someone
else has brought it into my life it's a
luxury showerhead no it doesn't do
anything we're like diddle in your
private parts instead it is a showerhead
in which you can put a scent cartridge
that when it is on it creates an aroma
aroma sense it makes sense that's not
their tagline and I'm not sponsored by
this product at all I just have enjoyed
it there is a lemon cartridge in my
aroma sense in my shower right now and
it is changed the game everything smells
like very mild lemon scent which is
wonderful it makes me feel like my
bathrooms cleaner than it actually is
and the water pressure has actually
increased on the showerhead which is
wonderful because before it was not the
best oh my god what a spoiled idiot
talking about water pressure I'm this
person now neck yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
not only am i showing you a showerhead
in this video but I'm showing you a
vacuum goodbye any millennial that stood
around thinking it might get better I
always say that I thought I became an
adult the first time I bought myself an
actual vacuum which is true that was a
very intense experience a very maturing
experience but now I think I'm a smart
adult because I bought myself a handheld
cordless vacuum for my house I'm in
Phase two of adulthood and this is a
cheat code it's a shark cordless vacuum
I got it at Target I think for 40 or 50
bucks and it comes with all of these
attachments or you can use it as is it
looks like the head of a camel wow it
really does or it looks like that head
of a horse from medieval times Oh No
look oh it's a horse sticking on this
tongue let me be your aunt it sits on a
power dock so it charges up so you can
just use it whenever you want
now you look great cool is it next yeah
you say yeah yeah say yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah let's talk about Fung Shui
nikodem Oh got me this book and thank
you Nikki I have finally gotten around
to starting to read it and I'm obsessed
Nikki and I turns out like really into
Tarot and astrology you got me this book
called move your stuff change your life
I started reading it last night and I'm
like so into it I spent most of today
Fung trying different rooms of my house
and I'm so anxious to get done shooting
this video so I can get back to Fung
Shui and go offense to you the one
person that's stuck around through the
vacuum and the showerhead it's a bunch
way if you don't know I'm gonna give you
a terrible definition of what it is in
Chinese it's not religion it's not
spirituality it's like a Chinese
practice of organizing your home so that
it provides energy for you in different
areas of your life and putting the right
colors elements things in the right
areas with the right attention that help
give energy to different areas of your
life it's meant to create harmony and
balance in your life and it's really
based on your own interpretation of the
basic principles of it so it's very
malleable and very flexible to solve a
verbal garbage that I have spitting at
you but trust me it's really interesting
I think it's cool
by Karen Ross Carter my favorite part
about this is that she tries to infuse
humor in how she describes funk which
way and this is Karen let's hit that
lady yeah Karen get it it's kind of
cheesy but in like a very entertaining
way to read it's super easy to read and
really easy to understand if you are
curious at all about feng shui or
desperate to change something in your
life that isn't working why not move
your stuff change your life alright
that's it for this episode
oh gosh was that shouldn't grace it's
Friday hey grace it's Friday thanks for
watching um let me know what you've been
liking this month and if you have any of
the things that I have talked about I'm
sure millions of you are excited to
finally have
place to talk about your favorite shower
heads and vacuums welcome and don't
forget to subscribe if you haven't
already it would be really lovely if you
did and I will see you when I see you I
don't know we're neglecting a shower
head to be the favorite of Grover and a
hamburger shirt for you know probably
work okay